alors je suis pas fabien oui alors je
suis max beurre de la chaîne big band
je suis là pour une raison particulière
c'est que fabien et moi eh ben on a
commencé la scène ensemble on s'est
lancé sur youtube tous les deux cette
année
et là on est tous les deux sur le point
de franchir le cap des 200 milles
abonnés donc voilà fabien simplement mon
pire ennemi y jeter l'écolabel félicité
voilà parce que c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant talents autour du mentalisme
faut savoir qu'il ya trois bombes sujet
à faire sur mentalisme 5 en étant sapa
donc c'était pas gagné mais voilà grâce
à sa sympathie et sa créativité
le mec a réussi comme ça à fidéliser
enfin fidéliser mais qui mentalist
maîtrise l'hypnose un gars se trouvent
ces vidéos elles sont bourrés une image
subliminale qui force ton subconscient
aux abonnés ce qu'elle essayait vous
souvenir du jour où êtes abonné à fabien
olicard vous souvenez maintenant
souvient pas des américaines et je vous
invite marie-eve occasion à venir
découvrir ce que je fais sur ma chaîne
fut démoli des idées reçues donc voilà
c'est la vulgarisation scientifique
c'est clair c'est constructif s'est
décalé et surtout ça ne parle pas de
mentalisme en vraie justice il va passer
les 200 milles avant moi que si vous
pouviez juste né vous abonner à ma
chaîne juste les basses en même temps
joêl par les mini jeux vous loue puis
elle au max on se fait plaisir sur ma
chaîne c'est bien c'est bien mais par
contre aurait peut-être pas dû du coup
laissé la tienne sans surveillance parce
que pendant que tu étais chez moi je me
suis permis d'aller faire un petit tour
chez toi et si vous voulez voir ce que
j'ai fait sur les chaînes de max clic et
je mets un lien dans la description
après j'avoue je vous recommande d'en
profiter pour garder tout son travail
vraiment vous allez kiffer bon et puis
comme aujourd'hui apparemment c'est une
journée spéciale où max à pirater ma
chaîne bat ya eu la vidéo
donc rendez vous demain à 17h cha vous
là